we are outside the Staples Center we're
actually joined now by cowboy a friend
of nipsey's who is inside for the
memorial
thanks for being here at cowboy as I
understand you said you were actually
there at the marathon clothing store the
night that nipsey got shot what can you
tell us about that night and what do you
remember just a lot of emotions going on
the whole city's erupted we all been in
tears morning morning MC uh
ever since that days has been a it's
been like an endless dream you know a
nightmare you know but uh it's a lot of
good that's been coming out of it a lot
of a lot of peace in the city the LAPD
they've been there for us
the Muslims they've been there for us
City Council members and came down the
city uh everybody the whole city
everybody's been supportive so do you
mind me asking where exactly you were
that night that the shooting happened
well I just I was talking to nipsey from
the time he got to that parking lot I
was I was out there talking to him I
just got my food and uh I left to the
break room and put my food down for a
short one minute amount of time and uh
and that's when the guy came up and shot
him so when you came back
Nipsey was on the ground and the guy was
breaking up out of there you know it's
not ran straight to nipsey and uh hell
to make sure he's breathing uh he was
still grieving uh he had a bullet hole
right here I kept my hand and that right
there got one right here he was fighting
he's he fought he fought you know you
can see fighting he wasn't trying to go
nowhere he was fighting he fought the
whole way up into the ambulance came and
goddamn he fought he's a fighter and
what were you telling him and in those
moments that you were holding them and
making sure he was there
I was best his praying praying praying
and uh because I start to roll back a
little bit I said we didn't wake up and
he's trying to snap back out of it I he
was kind of losing consciousness and
coming back so I save his fight and he's
just constantly fighting for it so I
just prayed and I shaking them shaking
them and uh telling you know wake up
stay up and stay up so uh he was
fighting me right cowboy you you said
that you were there talking to nipsey's
so obviously you guys had some kind of
relationship prior prior to what tell me
about the impact that nipsey had on your
life and in your relationship with
nipsey uh well you know nipsey nipsey
he was a friend you know at times he was
like a dad he gave me advice you know I
would give him advice you know with us
the whole team everybody's equals no it
was no big me little you everybody on
the team from the smallest job I don't
care what you did for the team you got
created an MC treated everybody equally
I didn't care what you did if he was a
bum on the street he didn't care he
would give you his time you know if he
was working he would do his work but if
he had time and he would give it to
anybody I know that nipsey obviously
spent a lot of time over at marathon and
certainly in that Square at crunch on
Slauson is that place you call home as
well yes every morning we meet up you
know we do shift change we drink I leave
you drinking tea he like the green tea
and uh you know I gave up cigarettes
this year I gave up coffee so I started
drinking tea every morning we drink our
tea or whatever and uh he'd go to the
studio and I start work you know so many
of us only know him as this artist you
know or a community activist you
obviously have a very personal
connection to him what's one thing we'd
be surprised to know about nip the the
human your friend I mean this is just
down-to-earth you know you know just his
sense of humor you know what I mean the
way you have fun you know they have
water fights they'd be in hotels tearing
up stuff you know just the kid aspect in
them uh like I say the fact that he's
never changed no matter what no matter
how much money God no matter how famous
he got he never changed he always said
in his music to about being present and
remembering all your humble beginnings
as well yeah cowboy thank you so much
chatting with this man and all the best
thank you for sharing your story much
appreciate your that that's right